(slow piano music)
- My job,
I enjoy it very much.
My contribution conservation,
it's something that make me
proud.
Working with rangers and
patrols,
with guides,
with animal trackers.
This is the best office in the
world.
(slow piano music)
- The growth of the
country and the energy,
it's almost duplicated in any
other sphere of the society,
so like,
coffee shops,
art centers,
you feel that energy.
The energy,
the creativity is part of the
whole fabric
of society right now.
It's a vibe.
(slow piano music)
- I'm trying to push the
boundaries
of things which are made in
Rwanda,
taking the inspiration from
what we have traditionally,
but make them more modern.
My inspiration for my designs,
the colorful patterns all over
Rwanda
and our tradition too.
I love to go in the market
and just watch people
how they combine colors.
It's beautiful.
- Nyungwe National Park
is a mountain rainforest.
It's a park rich in
biodiversity.
We have 13 species of primates,
more than 300 species of birds
and it's where we have the
fastest source of the Nile.
There is something special
that we need to protect.
(slow piano music)
- I'm proud of my country
because the resilience
and willingness to work hard,
to learn from each other.
Together, we'll go further
than if we work individually.
What's unique about Rwandan
coffee is the altitude,
the environment makes a huge
difference.
You get that smooth refreshing
taste
and we have won numerous awards.
- The past has a big influence
also to how I see Rwanda.
For example I use intore,
the traditional dancers.
It's beautiful and it's
graceful.
So that's what I wanted to
explain it in my clothes.
It's graceful but strong at the
same time.
- There's a word that
we use called agaciro.
Agaciro means the idea of self
worth,
self respect.
And it translates in
everything that we do.
- Agaciro means the dignity of
Rwandans,
working together,
put efforts together.
It makes me proud to be Rwandan.
- Agaciro for me it's a very
powerful word
which has so much meaning.
Be grateful,
be respectful,
be resilient,
be an example.
- There is a new change,
there is a new Rwanda being
created and I'm part of it.
- There's an energy that's out
there
welcoming every single
person to come visit Rwanda,
walk the streets,
talk to the people,
you'll be amazed what you
discover.
- Rwanda is a land of dream.